A miracle happened today for all immigrants and
international students in Canada
as the Ministry of immigration decided to clarify
their recent changes to the international
student program.
You do not wanna miss this.
The government website is as complicated as always
but I'm gonna break it down as an education
influencer so that you understand.
If you like this form in the videos,
make sure to follow.
We all heard about the provincial at a station
letter or PL
but now we know who doesn't need it
when applying for a study permit.
The postgrad work permit policy is pretty much the same.
You study for one year,
you get a one year PGWP,
study for two years,
get a three year PGWP.
However, now in one year
master's degree grants you
a three year postgrad work permit
but a one year postgrad
college certificate will only give you a one year PGWP.
Third one is just,
well I don't wanna make your life complicated
so just follow a simple rule.
Stay away from private
colleges that don't offer high quality education
if you want a postgrad work permit.
This one heavily touches future students.
You want to bring your spouse,
kids with you.
You will have to study a Masters or PhD level program
otherwise they wouldn't be eligible.
And here's more information for you to read through.
Important to remember
it's still being formulated.
Ircc emphasized the need for a letter of explanation
when you apply for A study permit.
The letter you just saw was generated by our AI
SOP builder.
So if you need help,
check it out.
The link will be in the bio.